es ist ein historischer Tag Putin droht
im Staatsfernsehen droht der ganzen Welt
gleichzeitig spricht ukraines Präsident
selenski im exklusiven Interview mit
Paul ronsheimer davon das Putin die
Ukraine in Blut ertrinken will
Deutschlands Kanzler spricht von einem
Akt der Verzweiflung seitens Putins und
gleich sehen Sie hierbei Bild live auch
US-Präsident Joe Biden in New York bei
der unvollversammlung es ist der große
kriegsangstgipfel kommt der Krieg auch
zu uns was bedeuten diese Drohungen
diese und viele andere Fragen die
besprechen wir jetzt mit Paul ronsheimer
uns zu gestaltet aus der Ukraine Bild
tv-chef Klaus Strunz ist bei uns und
unser Bild Militärexperte Julian
dir Ukraine dein Gespräch mit wohler du
mir selensky an diesem historischen Tag
nach den Drohungen nach der Teil
Mobilmachung Seiten Putins wie hast du
den Präsidenten empfunden bei diesem
Gespräch wird das wird dieser Tag
irgendetwas an der Strategie der Ukraine
verändern
Patricia ich hätte einen angespannten
Präsidenten erwartet als wir heute
Vormittag in die präsidentengebäude
gekommen sind da immer noch hohe
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen Sandsäcke
natürlich auch durch die Rede heute
morgen dann haben wir so eine knappe
Stunde auf silentski gewartet und das
erste was ich Ihnen natürlich gefragt
habe war ob er die Rede geschaut hat und
wir darauf reagiert und selenski hat
ganz entspannt gesagt ich habe mir das
gar nicht angeschaut das war für mich eh
klar dass das Referendum sogenannte Fake
Referendum kommen würde er hat sich dann
weiter entspannt gegeben und hat gesagt
das sei alles eingepreist also das ist
die offizielle Variante von selenski
aber auch neben der Kamera man hat ja so
ein bisschen das Gespür dafür ist das
jetzt gespielt oder ist das echt auch
danach wirkt er auf mich sehr sehr
entspannt im Vergleich zu den beiden
anderen Interviews die ich im Februar
und im April geführt habe mit ihm
entspannter und das ist natürlich
erstaunlich angesichts dieser
Schlagzeilen angesichts dessen das Putin
eben mit einem möglichen Atomschlag
offen noch einmal droht dass er von
einer Generalmobilmachung spricht und
wenn man sich das ganze anschaut sagt
aber silensky das ist am Ende ein
Zeichen der Schwäche ist und dass die
Ukraine auch das erstaunlich so
weitermachen wolle auch mit der
Offensive das heißt für die Strategie so
sagt silenski der gegen offensiven
bedeutet das gar nichts er sagt man will
mit Putin erst dann verhandeln wenn alle
Soldaten aus dem Land sind also auch da
rückt er davon ab vorher vor ein paar
Monaten hat er gesagt natürlich ist er
bereit sich sofort an einen Tisch zu
setzen aber jetzt klare Bedingungen noch
einmal formuliert
gleichzeitig ist ein Satz gefallen in
der Rede von Vladimir Putin im
Staatsfernsehen er sagte Klaus Strunz
das ist kein Blush dir dieser Satz Angst
gemacht naja also in einer solchen Phase
muss man natürlich die Rhetorik immer
ein bisschen
aufdröseln sozusagen wenn sich silensky
entspannt gibt ist das natürlich der
Versuch des Zeichen seiner Stärke und
wenn eine Putin sagt das ist kein blöff
dann nimmt der auf dass die gesamte
westliche Rhetoriker ist er würde nur
Blöcken und der habe eigentlich gar
nichts mehr was er noch groß mobil
machen könnte ich glaube das aber die
Wirkung auf die Menschen im Westen
insbesondere auf die Menschen in
Deutschland wir sind ja verdammt nah
dran an diesem Geschehen noch eine ganz
andere ist nämlich gar nicht so sehr die
Frage ob Vladimir Putin jetzt genug
Soldaten hat um in der Ukraine wieder
Land zu erobern oder ob er dann noch
genug Panzer hat die nicht im Schlamm
stecken bleiben oder ob er dann noch
genug wäre hat den nicht einfrieren im
Winter die Frage ist
aber vielleicht durch den Westen so in
die Enge gezwungen worden ist dass er
irgendwas verrücktes macht und die
eigentliche Frage ist hat er noch die
Kraft etwas Verrücktes zu machen und
wenn man zu der Antwort käme diese Kraft
hat er noch weil seine Umgebung noch zu
ihm steht weil der Weg zu dem berühmten
roten Knopf oder zu Aktivierung der
Atomraketen ihm noch offen steht dann
muss ich sagen kann ich das unbehagliche
Gefühl viele Leute teilen denn dann
würde ein angeschossener Wolf sozusagen
noch mal richtig in die Offensive gehen
und mit der letzten Verzweiflung das ist
auch das Wort was bei Scholz dass mir so
gemacht Putin sei verzweifelt ist eine
Verzweiflungstat verzweifelte Menschen
machen wenn sie die Kraft dazu haben
seltsame Dinge schlimme Dinge und
deshalb verstehe ich das heute auch so
ein Schaudern durch Deutschland geht was
bedeutet das jetzt alles und dann klar
ist es auch in der Verantwortung von
Politikern dass sie dieses schau dann
nicht noch bedienen sondern eigene
Stärke zeigen aber mein Gefühl ist die
wirklich Möglichkeit liegt hier irgendwo
zwischen den Fronten es ist nicht ganz
so entspannt wie selinski sich gibt und
es ist nicht ganz so gruselig wie der
blöffer aus Moskau es beschreibt lass
uns zusammen einmal auf die Rede
Reaktion von der Präsident selensky Sean
Paul du hast mit ihm darüber gesprochen
wie er das ganze auffasst was er darüber
denkt wenn Putin mit Atomwaffen droht
dass uns in diesen Aspekt noch einmal
reinschauen
ich glaube nicht dass er dieser Waffen
einsetzen wird
sogar so formulieren ich glaube nicht
dass die Welt es zulassen wird
wir können nicht in den Kopf von diesen
Menschen schauen es gibt riesige ja aber
wie soll es sein er wird immer androhen
Atomwaffen einzusetzen
wir können uns nicht auf diese
Kompromisse einlassen einen
entscheidender Satz Julian Röpke unser
Militärexperte hier bei Bild fällt dort
wir können nicht in den Kopf dieses
Menschen schauen wie bewertest du dieses
Risiko also ich würde sagen das Risiko
für uns hier im Westen ist aktuell
relativ gering weil ich möchte daran
erinnern am meisten hat sich die
russische Regierung darüber geärgert als
wir die Wiese eingefroren haben als wir
die Visa nicht mehr gegeben haben das
heißt was die russische Regierung
wirklich wirklich nervt zurzeit ist das
die Russen nicht mehr in ihre Anwesenden
in ihre Häuser nach Berlin nach London
und nach Marseille reisen dürfen und
wenn wir das im Auge behalten oder
Hinterkopf zumindest behalten dann
können wir auch sagen dass
wahrscheinlich einen nuklearer Asche
gelegtes Berlin oder London und Marcel
den Russen nicht gerade gefallen würde
auch den russischen Bürgern
nichtsdestotrotz sie ist genauso wie
Klaus strunzmann muss diese Drohung
ernst nehmen und es ist ja nicht zum
ersten Mal dass sie so Drogen fällt wir
haben in den letzten Tagen gerade eben
weil es für die Russen sehr sehr
schlecht läuft in der Ukraine wir
erinnern uns an diesen riesigen Rückzug
in Raki wir erinnern uns an die
offensiven antonetts und du Hans die
völlig eingefroren sind da man wird
diese sogenannten Volksrepublik nicht
befreien können mit konventionellen
Mitteln wir haben von russischen
militärblockern gehört die sehr sehr nah
bei der Armee sind wir müssen alle zwölf
Stunden eine taktische Atombombe auf dem
Westen der Ukraine feuern und so lange
das machen bis die aufgeben das halte
ich aktuell noch für Zukunftsmusik aber
genau diese politischen Spielchen die
Putin jetzt treibt wie annektieren das
ist das ist das ist dann angeblich
russischer Boden und wer Russland
angreift der muss auch mit unseren
nuklearnacht rechnen das spielt da schon
so ein bisschen rein und ich glaube man
muss wie gesagt auch wenn ich ich glaube
das aktuelle ist diese Drogen ernst
nimmt
300.000 Reservisten so viel ist am
heutigen Tag klar die müssen jetzt an
die Front und zwar sofort hollandsheimer
aus der Ukraine zugeschaltet was
bedeutet das für die Weiterentwicklung
dieses Krieges die Gegenoffensive die
läuft ja seitens der Ukraine
es bedeutet in jedem Fall dass es
schwieriger wird für die Ukraine diese
weiteren Gebiete einzunehmen alles was
eine Front zum Beispiel im Osten also
nukans gedonnets Region stabilisiert
oder auch im Süden in razon bedeutet
eine schwieriger werdende Offensive der
Ukraine ob das am Ende bedeutet dass Sie
keine weiteren Gebiete erobern können
das ist unklar denn momentan ist es so
dass die Russen dort vor allem
logistisch massive Probleme haben also
es reicht nicht zu sagen wir schicken
jetzt einfach mal schnell so ein paar
Soldaten rüber das geht auch gar nicht
so schnell denn es gibt große Probleme
in Russland überhaupt Soldaten zu
rekrutieren deswegen haben wir diese
Bilder gesehen wo versucht wurde
Gefangene zu rekrutieren teilweise
Mörder das ist etwas was dort gerade
passiert und wir erleben in der Ukraine
auf der anderen Seite tatsächlich eine
neue Euphorie kann man fast den
Motivation dass sie das in dieser
Richtung schaffen können aber man muss
vielleicht noch einmal erklären warum
macht Putin das alles gerade das macht
er weil er natürlich sieht dass die
Ukraine Boden gewinnen und vor allem die
Referenten sind für Putin da
entscheidend also er will jetzt eine
klare Grenze ziehen und wir sagen dass
bestimmte Regionen im Osten und im Süden
dann wenn diese fake-referenten
stattgefunden haben russisch sind und
dann verbindet er das ganze auch mit
einer Drohung an den Westen im Sinne von
wer in diese Gebiete geht der greift
direkt russisches Land an jetzt kann man
sagen ja es gab schon Angriffe auf die
Krim es gab auch Angriffe auf
Munitionslager an der Grenze aber das
ist jetzt noch mal ganz neu emotional
auch aus Putins Sicht hochgepeitscht das
Thema das heißt für ihn geht es jetzt
auch um Alles oder nicht er hat sich
dafür entschieden dass er sagt eine
teilmobilisierung machen wir und jetzt
muss er aus sich Putins diesen Krieg
zumindest ja insofern drehen dass die
Ukraine nicht noch weiteres Gebiet
gewinnen und das setzt ihn natürlich
auch persönlich unter Druck gleichzeitig
eröffnet er sich damit natürlich auch
die Möglichkeit schneller zu reagieren
und diese Angriffe dann zurechtfertigen
weil er eben sagt das ist ein Angriff
auf russisches Staatsgebiet was glaubst
Du Julian wie wird das diesen Krieg auch
noch einmal beeinflussen dass er also
diese Grenzen jetzt selbst setzt und
dann mit seinen Propaganda Mitteln somit
auch andere taten rechtfertigen kann
ja das ist tatsächlich die große Frage
wir haben schon gehört 300.000 Mann
wären die einen Unterschied machen ich
glaube das ist die große Frage und ich
habe heute mit der Ben Hodges gesprochen
im ehemaligen Kommandeur der der
US-Armee in Europa der 7 US-Armee und
der hat noch mal gesagt das ist im
Endeffekt Kanonenfutter was da angeholt
wird erstmal wie Paul gesagt hat es
dauert Monat Monat um die Leute
reinzuholen zweitens wo ordnet man die
einen packt man die einfach sagt man da
ist und viel Spaß setzt sich dahin das
ist alles nicht klar auf jeden Fall sind
das Leute die überhaupt gar keine
modernen Waffen mehr haben wir haben das
in den letzten Wochen immer wieder
gesehen russland hat zuerst die modernen
Panzer genommen im Februar dann sind die
weggegangen hat man die aus den 80ern
genommen jetzt nimmt man die t62 Panzer
die ab 1956 gebaut wurden und diese
Panzer wir haben doch heute aktuelle
Fotos gesehen gesehen sind auf dem Weg
in die Ukraine auf Zügen ich muss doch
als russischer Soldat mich wirklich
dreimal Fragen möchte ich mich als
30-jähriger Mann in einen 60-jährigen
Panzer setzen der seit 40 Jahren nicht
mehr benutzt wurde ich glaube bei den
Russen selbst die haben eine gewisse
Ahnung gerade die die schon mal im
Militär gedient haben
ruft das ganz ganz dunkle Gefühle heraus
da überhaupt hingehen zu müssen und ich
glaube nicht dass diese Menschen
hochmotiviert sind an der Front zu
kämpfen vor allem wenn sie ihre noch mal
ihre doppelt so alten wie sie Waffen
sehen
lass uns gemeinsam noch mal reinschauen
zumindest einen hatte die Teil mobil
machen nicht überrascht und das war
Ukrainisch Präsident selenski auch
darüber hast du im Interview mit ihm
gesprochen dass uns da gemeinsam noch
einmal reinschauen
es ist nichts Neues für mich
er hat das gleiche getan
darüber gesprochen aber er hat eine
Mobilmachung durchgeführt unsere
Geheimdienste und unsere Verbündete
haben das schon gesagt den ganzen
letzten Monat hatte die
immobilienmachung durchgeführt
Klaus Strunz heute morgen sind wir
erwachter im Putin im Staatsfernsehen
gesehen von ukrainischer Seite heißt das
keine Überraschung damit haben wir
gerechnet und dennoch müssen wir alle
zugeben dass uns das alle heute bewegt
das ist auch angstauslösen kann dass man
sich fragt wie soll dieser Krieg
überhaupt weitergehen bzw für ihr wie
soll dieser Krieg jemals ein Ende finden
wie weit wird Putin gehen ich glaube die
die Antwort ist
kompliziert man kann sie aber nur finden
wenn man sie allein aus Vladimir Putin
ableitet Vladimir Putin ist es ja die
Endschlacht in allem denn wenn er jetzt
Frieden schlösse wäre es schon sehr sehr
schwierig Politiker des Westens
überhaupt mit ihnen an ihm an einen
Tisch zu kriegen haben viele
verschiedene schon erklärt das würden
sie nie mehr machen andere haben die Tür
offen gelassen aber er kommt dann als
Personal und gerade an den
Verhandlungstisch das ist etwas was für
jemanden wie Vladimir Putin schlimmer
ist als jede Krankheit die er sich
vorstellen kann als ein völlig
entwaffneter geschlagen hat dann ja
schließ Mann an ein Verhandlungstisch zu
kommen also wird er das Ganze aus einer
sieger-position denken und er wird für
sich jetzt die Frage beantworten müssen
was kriegt er noch einigermaßen
glaubhaft als Sieg verkauft und danach
macht sich alles fest deswegen wird
schon ganz interessant sein ob diese
drei mobil machen überhaupt klappt also
wenn massenhaft junge Leute was ich
heute gesehen habe bei Google suchen wie
man sich den Arm brechen kann kann das
ja nur bedeuten sie wollen sich dann
hier reinberufung entziehen wenn das zum
Signal wird für dass er nicht mal mehr
in der Lage ist seine eigenen Leute zu
mobilisieren wäre das richtungsweisend
in diesem in diesem Krieg und krieg ist
ja auch das Stichwort ich finde das
Signal nach innen an die russische
Bevölkerung ist ja jetzt UI wir sind in
einem Krieg verwickelt denn für so ein
Manöver irgendwo in der Ukraine oder für
so ein Sondereinsatz war glaube ich
immer die in einer Sonderkommando ein
Sondereinsatz war immer die Formulierung
die man nur verwenden konnte da braucht
man echt keine Thai mobil machen von
300.000 Soldaten das heißt jetzt langsam
ich sag's mal ein bisschen flapsig fällt
bei immer mehr Russen der Groschen was
eigentlich jetzt gerade passiert mit
ihnen ihrem Land
ihren Söhnen Männern
und so weiter das was bisher nicht
ausgesprochen werden durfte ist jetzt
offenbar und das könnte der innere Spiel
entscheidende Zug sein um Wladimir Putin
zu Fall zu bringen denn das glaube ich
muss ja die Konsequenz sein ich kann mir
ein Wladimir Putin nach dieser
Auseinandersetzung nach diesem Krieg im
Amt nicht vorstellt entweder er ist weg
dann gibt es die Möglichkeit Frieden zu
schließen und mit Russland in neue in
ein neues Verhältnis zu kommen oder es
noch da dann wird es verdammt dann
verdammt schwierig mit ihm etwas zu tun
finde ich das sind dann auch moralische
Grenzen glaube ich für die Politik von
entscheidender Bedeutung sehr ähnlich
hat das ja Paul auch silensky im
Gespräch mit dir formuliert ist ihr
darüber gesprochen hat was muss
eigentlich mit Vladimir Putin passieren
du hast ihn ja auch gefragt würde es sie
freuen wenn Vladimir Putin tot wäre wie
war da seine Reaktion
ja würde mir selensky hat da erstmal
klar gesagt das ist anders sieht als
Ursula von der Leyen mit der ich darüber
genau vor einer Woche fast gesprochen
habe die gesagt hat man dürfe sich
grundsätzlich nicht über den Tod eines
Menschen freuen sie wünsche sich aber
das Wladimir Putin vor Gericht gestellt
wird und selensky hat es nicht
ausgesprochen aber angedeutet und
darüber gesprochen wie groß der Hass ist
eben gegenüber russischen Soldaten die
in die Ukraine gekommen sind und
natürlich auch gegenüber Wladimir Putin
er hat natürlich muss man fast sagen aus
politischen Gründen nicht gesagt im
O-Ton dass er sich darüber freuen würde
denn würde mir selenski weiß genau
welche Worte er hier in dieser Situation
wählen muss auch um seine Partner nicht
zusätzlich zu brüskieren denn das ist ja
auch eine große Frage für die Ukraine
wie wird jetzt Olaf Scholz wie wird Joe
Biden darauf reagieren Stellen die sich
weiter komplett hinter silence die
Ukraine liefern sie möglicherweise sogar
mehr Waffen ich habe mit ihm ja auch
darüber gesprochen da dann noch mal klar
gesagt hat kein Verständnis dafür dass
Deutschland weiterhin darauf verzichtet
keine Kampfpanzer hierher zu schicken
hat gesagt da kann man nicht die Ausrede
finden die USA und London und und
Großbritannien schicken auch keine
sondern da müsste man was tun und dann
einen erstaunlicher Satz er hat gesagt
als ich ihn gefragt habe ob er manchmal
Flucht und laut Olaf Scholz brüllt in
seinem Büro hat er gelacht aber dann
zugegeben dass häufiger mal die Wände
gewackelt haben also diese Spannung die
sind dort immer noch vorhanden und der
Druck auch auf würde mir selenski
natürlich auch in im Land aber
international da bleibt natürlich riesig
und der entlädt sich dann
insbesondere muss man sagen immer wieder
Richtung Deutschland lass uns gemeinsam
in diesen Ausschnitt aus deinem
Interview noch einmal reinschauen Paul
du hast mit wohler mir selensky darüber
gesprochen dass er mehr aktive Hilfe in
Deutschland erwartet
schauen Sie
ein Mensch ist in einem Fluss
der Mensch ertrinkt
und sie sind am Ufer und ein Streit
helfen sie mir
und am Ufer
Laute die Antwort warten Sie die
Abgeordneten müssen erst mal abstimmen
verstehen sie das ich verstehe das nicht
ich finde
wir müssen den Menschen helfen ich wurde
selbst in den Fluss gehen und den
Menschen retten das wünsche ich mir von
Bundeskanzler und vom deutschen Volk
wissen wir die Ukraine trinken Julian
Röpke in der kampfpanzerfrage blockiert
der Kanzler weiterhin lassen wir also
die Ukraine ertrinken
ich glaube wir liefern weiterhin zu
wenig zu spät aber ich sehe auch
Bewegung und wir haben seit Anfang des
Krieges wir erinnern uns bis zum
kriegstagsausbruch wo andere schon
tausende Panzerabwehrwaffen geschickt
hatten und der Kanzler nichts machen
wollte weil er gesagt hat wir haben hier
Frieden und wir so bleibt das auch da
haben wir dann an dem Tag haben wir
angefangen mit diesen Waffen zu stellen
danach haben wir angefangen okay wir
schicken die allerersten kleinen
Fahrzeuge mittlerweile sind wir bei
Panzerhaubitzen wir sind bei Bergepanzer
wir sind bei Dingos die sind gepanzerten
Fahrzeuge 50 Stück davon wurden jetzt
gerade beschlossen wir sind bei diesen
Mars 2 das hört sich erstmal das nicht
an aber diese Maß 2 ist eine der
mächtigsten Waffen ja super vergleichen
mit den amerikanischen Heimat die
Ukrainer haben nur das Beste über die zu
sagen das heißt wir haben diesen glaube
ich diesen Point of no Return schon
lange überschritten bei den
Waffenlieferung man hört das auch von
Olaf Scholze sagt jetzt nicht etwa jetzt
müssen wir vielleicht anfangen zu
verhandeln sondern er sagt der Putin das
ist ein ganz klarer imperialist was wir
da sehen und ich glaube
ja er zaudert noch und wir sehen auch
das weitere das muss man einfach so
sagen auch Herr beiden zaubert noch ich
glaube aber dass immer stärkere und
immer mehr westliche Waffen in der
Ukraine sehen werden sowohl aus
Deutschland als auch an alles andere
NATO-Ländern und sollte Putin jetzt
wirklich diese Gebiete annektieren und
ja Gott bewahre tatsächlich andere
Waffen einsetzen als bisher noch
tödlichere Waffen dann glaube ich sind
tatsächlich da sind die die da würde er
die Tore zur Hölle öffnen was
nato-unterstützung angeht für die
Ukraine und das sollte er sich wirklich
ganz genau überlegen Klaus wie bewertest
du die Rolle Deutschlands jetzt in
diesem Krieg auch angesichts jetzt der
neuen Eskalation würde ich bin ja immer
sehr dafür wer genau zuzuhören wenn
Bundespolitiker insbesondere der
Bundeskanzler was sagt und da er selber
ja so viel vergisst im Laufe der Zeit
ist es gut dass man das
genau macht und der hat wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe vorhin ja gesagt
dass wir an der Seite des Rechts stehen
und nicht an der Seite der Gewalt und
jetzt ist es aber so und es wird ihm
auch klar sein dass man manchmal Gewalt
braucht um Recht durchzusetzen und mit
dieser Formulierung hat er aus meiner
Sicht schon die Tür noch ein Stückchen
weiter
aufgest Wissen über die Julian gerade
geredet hat eben diese Entwicklung hin
zu wir tun es dann doch sozusagen er ist
eindeutig fortgeschritten und jetzt
fehlt im Grunde nur noch die Exekution
es zu tun ich will aber auch mal einen
Gedanken für Olaf Scholz in in die
Diskussion werfen ich finde es ich finde
ihn langsam und behäbig und ich habe
mich 20 mal aufgeregt warum nicht
schneller und nicht entschlossener aber
so ein bisschen fühle ich mich auch
regiert von einem Mann der nicht wie ein
Heißsporn sozusagen sofort sagt im
ersten Moment und jetzt schicken wir
unsere Panzer und wenn es sein muss
schicken wir die Bundeswehr und wenn es
sein muss gehe ich zu Herrn Stoltenberg
dem nato-chef und bedränge den dass wir
das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz
seriös und wenn er jetzt noch quasi den
den letzten Schubs sich selber gibt oder
es gibt ihm irgendjemand in seiner
Umgebung die Grünen werden vielleicht
nicht sein obwohl das weiß man in der
verrückten Zeit ja auch nicht mehr dann
glaube ich kommt es auch zu den
Waffenlieferungen
Putin auch in der Sprache zu begegnen
der einzigen die er versteht da geht's
nicht um deutsch oder russisch oder
sowas da geht es um die Sprache von
Macht und von Stärke und von Muskeln
zeigen und von Waffen zeigen was ist
denn das Wortes und wer sich daran nicht
beteiligt wer daran davor zurückschreckt
der kann noch so gute Gründe haben er
wird im Gegenteil es Weichling
erscheinen und das darf jetzt in dieser
entscheidenden Phase eigentlich nicht
mehr bestehen Paul wie nennt man ihnen
der Ukraine war du hast ja auch mit
silensky darüber gesprochen natürlich
wünscht er sich da schnellere Waffen
eine härtere Waffen vor allem
Kampfpanzer dort ist es so dass jeder
Tag zählt besonders jetzt die gegen
Offensive läuft wie nennt man die
zögernde Rolle des Kanzlers dort war
ja ich finde es schon erstaunlich
eigentlich wenn man die letzten Wochen
betrachtet wie sehr Deutschland hier
immer noch Buhmann ist dann ist es ja
nun nicht so dass Deutschland gar nichts
geliefert hätte und auch eben schweres
Gerät geliefert hat und an dieser
panzerfrage lässt sich das ja
interessant beobachten da wird auch aus
der Ukraine immer ausschließlich mit dem
Finger auf Deutschland gezeigt also
Leopard und so weiter und so fort das
hat sicherlich auch mit der politischen
Diskussion in Deutschland zu tun weil da
ja eben in der Koalition so laute
Stimmen sind von stark Zimmermann über
Hofreiter die den Kanzler dort
kritisieren ich glaube es zeigt sich
auch hier ein massives
Kommunikationsproblem von Olaf Scholz
denn er rennt der Sache immer hinterher
von Markus Söder sagt man wenn der in
eine Sitzung geht dann weiß er vorher
was für eine Schlagzeile bei rauskommen
soll und bei Olaf Scholz na ja ist das
auch eine Woche später noch nicht klar
das kann man ja sympathisch finden aber
gerade in dieser Waffen Frage sor ist
natürlich dafür dass es große
Missverständnisse immer wieder gibt dann
am Anfang hat er gesagt nein wir sagen
nicht was wir liefern dann doch ein
bisschen aber keine schweren Waffen dann
doch schwere Waffen jetzt will er keine
Panzer aber dann vielleicht doch
irgendwie Panzer also er ist immer
hinten dran in der Kommunikation in der
wahren Statistik ist er jetzt nicht
Letzter er ist nicht erster aber wenn
man diese Debatte im Kampfpanzer sich
anschaut das habe ich das letzte ja auch
gefragt warum immer Deutschland wenn die
USA und Großbritannien zumindest jetzt
noch keine Kampfpanzer schicken da hat
er gesagt auch wieder auf Deutschland na
ja die sollen sich davon lösen also ich
glaube dass Olaf Scholz bei aller Kritik
die auch ich immer wieder äußere dadurch
ein bisschen besser zumindest da steht
als man das hier in der Ukraine wahr
haben will wenn man sich die gesamte
Statistik anschaut jetzt gerade ist er
in New York hat dort eine Rede gehalten
und hat auch heute am heutigen wirklich
historischen Tag noch einmal gesprochen
der Kanzler in New York was sagt er zur
neuen Eskalation des Krieges was sagt er
zu der Ankündigung Putins einer
teilmobilisierung und vor allem auch zur
Drohung zur erneuten Atomwaffen Drohung
gehen Westen lasst uns gemeinsam noch
einmal in die Worte des Kanzlers
reinschauen
die jüngsten Entscheidungen der
russischen Regierung sind ein Akt der
Verzweiflung Russland kann diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg nicht gewinnen
und mit den jüngsten Entscheidungen
macht Putin macht Russland das alles nur
noch viel schlimmer er hat von Anfang an
die Situation komplett unterschätzt den
Widerstand und den Widerstandswillen der
ukraineren Ukraine aber auch die
Geschlossenheit und Entschlossenheit der
Freunde der Ukraine
die jetzt angekündigten scheinreferenten
werden niemals akzeptiert werden
natürlich nicht vom ukrainischen Volk
aber auch nicht von der Weltgemeinschaft
und können deshalb keine Rechtfertigung
dafür bieten was Russland tatsächlich
vor hat nämlich mit Gewalt das Land des
Nachbarn zu erobern oder Teile des
Territoriums davon das wird niemals
akzeptiert werden können in der Welt in
der wir leben muss das Recht über die
gewaltigen und kann nicht die Gewalt
stärker sein als das Recht
Klaus Strunz wie bewertest du dieses
Statement des Kanzlers wie wirkt er auch
auf dich angesichts dessen ist ganz
viele Menschen jetzt in Deutschland die
Angst fühlt und auch die Frage quält wie
weit wird Putin gehen wird er wirklich
Atomwaffen einsetzen und wie könnte dann
die Reaktion des Westens ausfallen also
gut der Stadt jetzt für mich nicht so
aus als würde irgendeiner vor ihm groß
Angst haben wenn da irgendwas sagt und
auch bei dem Gleichnis dass man ja gern
hat würde man in einer Krisensituation
diesen Mann Folgen aus einem brennenden
Haus bin ich nicht ganz sicher aber er
sagt natürlich kluge Sachen vor allem
sagt er Putin habe die Situation
unterschätzt und ich würde das einmal
gerne Spiegeln und sagen das ist ja
quasi die absolute Aufforderung an den
Westen jetzt die jetzige Situation nicht
zu unterschätzen also Putina die
Situation unterschätzt weil er sich in
im Vorteil während des Krieges jetzt
wähnt sich irgendwie die Ukraine in der
Offensive noch nicht richtig im Vorteil
aber wenn du Offensive und
offensichtlich tendiert man
Moment einer relativen Stärke dazu die
andere Seite zu unterschätzen also mahnt
Olaf Scholz mit dieser Formulierung auch
sich selbst womit wir wieder bei der
Frage sind wer hilft dann wem womit und
da ist er glaube ich innerlich so
deutlich auch diesen Auftritt in Amerika
jetzt da ist er innerlich glaube ich
jetzt schon entschlossen auch noch den
nächsten Schritt zu gehen und Panzer zu
liefern also die panzerfrage da könnte
es doch noch zur Wende kommen für wie
wahrscheinlich hältst du das Paul
ronsheimer
[Musik]
ich glaube dass diese Wände tatsächlich
kommen kann aber Olaf Scholz hat einmal
gesagt erwartet jetzt auf die Amerikaner
und Franzosen da kann er jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr raus und
alleine was machen man muss ja sagen in
den vergangenen Tagen ist in Sachen
Haubitzen noch etwas geliefert worden
und auch Dingos also gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge sind geliefert worden ich gehe
davon aus dass diese Wände irgendwann
kommen könnte und dann glaube ich wird
es wirklich spannend denn mit dem was
Wladimir Putin heute gesagt hat auch mit
der
Aggressivität gegenüber dem Westen muss
man dann schon diskutieren ob er dann
sozusagen diesen Schritt wenn der Westen
sagt okay wir sind jetzt auch bereit
Kampfpanzer zu liefern ob er diesen
Schritt dann wieder nutzen wird um was
auch immer zu tun aber das ist natürlich
etwas was in Olaf Scholz Kopf jetzt
arbeitet er ist am Ende derjenige der
die Entscheidung treffen muss und auch
auch wieder sagt dass er eben Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abwenden will genauso
wie er immer wenden muss genauso wieder
der Ukraine helfen will und das ist
etwas was sicherlich Wladimir Putin
psychologisch insbesondere durch die
Ansprache heute morgen erreicht hat dass
sich Kanzler Olaf Scholz und
US-Präsident Joe Biden möglicherweise
noch mehr quälen werden der Ukraine mehr
zu liefern und das ist etwas was dann
hier in der Ukraine natürlich für
Unverständnis sorgen würde wenn das denn
so wäre aber das ist mein Eindruck so
schätze ich Olaf Scholz ein dass er
schon Sorge hat
Julian Röpke und sanitärexperte auch du
hast einen ganz genauen Blick auf die
militärische Entwicklung im Land und es
entsteht so sagt man eine Art Momentum
die Gegenoffensive in Teilen sehr sehr
erfolgreich deine Einschätzung nach was
braucht die Ukraine um dieses Momentum
auszubauen und wie groß ist deine
Hoffnung darauf dass das auch gelingt
also ich glaube die Ukraine hat
mittlerweile schon eine ganze Menge
Waffen bekommen die ihr dabei helfen
können das sind leider keine Panzer und
schützen Panzer es sind aber viele
andere Panzerfahrzeuge und wir haben den
letzten Tagen und Wochen gesehen dass
die Ukraine tatsächlich aus ja aus
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen zum Beispiel Max
pro von den Amerikanern oder Kirby aus
Türkei waren wir auch über 200 Stück
bekommen dass sie daraus so eine Art
kleine Panzer gemacht haben das heißt
sie haben da zwei Leute drauf gesetzt
die Maschinengewehr nach vorne nach
vorne schießen haben weitere sechs Leute
acht Leute reingepackt die so sagen sich
damit bewegt haben sind dann schnell vor
durch die gegnerischen Linie dann frag
ich wann wir das gesehen und haben die
Russen völlig überrascht und die Russen
haben wir haben das gesehen sie haben
aufgegeben sie hatten dort eine
überlegene militärische Macht sie hatten
dort extrem viel Artillerie sie hatten
Panzer aber als sie nicht mehr genau
wussten wo der Gegner steht ob er hinter
ihnen steht ob er vor ihnen steht ob
vielleicht eine Spezialeinheit schon an
ihm vorbeigefahren ist da sind die
Russen zu 10.000 aus Raki geflüchtet und
haben über 400 von ihrem
Panzerfahrzeugen zurückgelassen und ich
glaube das macht eben die Ukraine aus
dass sie ihm völlig innovativ ist dass
sie teilweise auch diese westlichen
Taktik hat des schnellen vorstoßens und
Lichtes ich gucke mir genau an wo der
Gegner steht dass man eben auch
zusammenarbeitet dass sie Luftwaffe
zusammen mit der Artillerie zusammen mit
den mit den Infanterie Verbänden und den
mechanisierten Infanterie voranstürmt
und ich glaube das ist der große
Unterschied dass sie eben von einer
Sowjet Armee zum oder auch von der
russischen Armee eben unterscheidet und
womit sie sehr erfolgreich vorangehen
es bleibt jetzt abzuwarten die Russen
haben ja wieder abgezogen und können
jetzt wieder das vorhandene sage ich mal
mit Material was sie noch haben auch an
Soldaten auf die bestehenden Fronten
verteilen das heißt die werden noch mal
fester ja wir haben das schon Ende
Februar Ende März Anfang April erlebt wo
man sich von Kiew zum Norden
zurückgezogen hat da hat man plötzlich
eine viel festere und teilweise auch
erfolgreiche Front im Osten gehabt das
kann jetzt noch mal passieren ich sehe
aber trotzdem die Dynamik relativ
eindeutig die Ukraine dringend in
Donetsk vor die Ukrainer dringend in du
Hans vor und Ukraine Song vor das sind
die drei Regionen wo jetzt die
Referenten stattfinden sollen wir sehen
also ein ruhiges genommen zur was auch
immer zum Anschluss an Russland wird es
da überhaupt nicht geben es wird ein
Referendum geben währenddessen sich die
russischen Truppen zurückziehen müssen
weil die Ukrainer voranstürmen und
gleichzeitig ist diese Dynamik Julian
von der du auch sprichst ja auch mit ein
Grund dafür dass Putin jetzt heute die
Teilmobilmachung verkündet hat dass er
solche deutlichen und aggressiven
Drohungen ausspricht dass uns gemeinsam
noch mal in die Worte von Vladimir Putin
reinschauen er hat das heute ausstrahlen
lassen 13 Stunden später als geplant im
Staatsfernsehen der Kriegstreiber
Vladimir Putin
ich möchte diejenigen die solche
Äußerungen über Russland machen daran
erinnern dass auch unser Land über
verschiedene zerstörungsmittel verfügt
und in einigen Fällen sind sie moderner
als die der NATO-Länder dies ist kein
Bluff und diejenigen die versuchen uns
mit Atomwaffen zu erpressen sollten
wissen dass sich die Wetterfahne drehen
und auf sie zeigen kann
das sind also die Worte die heute sorgen
machen die Angst machen und die auch zum
Nachdenken anregen über die Reaktionen
aus der Ukraine und auch aus dem Westen
darüber habe ich gesprochen mit Paul
ronsheimer er hat wiederum heute
exklusiv gesprochen mit ukraines
Präsident silensky der von der Androhung
Putins alles andere als überrascht war
auch im Studio ist unser Bild tv-chef
Klaus Strunz gewesen und unser
militär-experte Julian Röpcke vielen
herzlichen Dank euch allen für diese
Einschätzungen an diesem historischen
Tag
[Musik]